La Prof:
Ok.
Si je pouvais vous aider, je le ferais, mais
je vois pas quoi faire,
je sais pas voyager dans le temps...
Aliénor:
J'ai une idée! On tourne une vidéo où
on explique à la cyber-historienne tout ce
qu'on pense de ses méthodes, on lui donne
un titre putaclic pour la rendre virale, et
comme ça dans deux siècles elle aura tellement
circulé que tout le monde la connaîtra et
que la cyber-historienne la verra!
Astrid:
Si je peux me permettre, c'est complètement con.
Lucretia:
Tu peux te le permettre.
Aliénor:
D'accord, alors j'attends vos idées.
Si on avait commencé à soumettre l'agent
aux ordalies, il aurait pas filé!
La Prof:
C'est pas le problème, mais il y a de fortes
chances que lui ou un autre revienne pour
finir leur travail...
Et là on le choppe, on lui prend sa machine
à voyager dans le temps, et on y va.
Agent:
Euh...
C'est encore moi...
Aliénor:
Attrapez-le!
Agent:
Me torturez pas s'il vous plaît, je reviens
de la part de votre cyber-historienne! Elle
veut vous rencontrer.
Lucretia:
Parfait.
Aliénor:
Godefroy?!
Godefroy:
Aliénor!
Lucretia:
Tu connais ce gueux?
L'agent:
La Prof! Votre cyber-historienne va vous recevoir.
Aliénor, Lucretia:
Bonne chance!
Astrid:
Bute-la.
La Prof:
Je note que vous n'avez pas de gadgets ultra
perfectionnés, pour un homme du XXIIIe siècle.
A part votre appareil à voyager dans le temps,
je veux dire.
L'agent:
Je n'ai pas le droit de commenter mon époque.
Pour nous, vous êtes une ancêtre, comme
celles que vous avez ramenées avec vous.
Vous en savez déjà beaucoup trop.
La Prof:
Tout ce que je sais, c'est que les historiens
de votre époque sont incroyablement sous-doués.
Ça suffit à faire de moi une menace?
L'agent:
Ce sera à votre descendante d'en décider.
Entrez, elle vous attend.
Cyber-historienne:
Bonjour.
Ancêtre numéro 9.
Vous m'avez causé une montagne de problèmes,
à récupérer les ancêtres que je comptais interroger.
La Prof:
Jalouse ?
Cyber-historienne:
Pas vraiment, quand je vois le lot dont vous avez hérité.
Il me reste à décider comment mettre fin
à cette anomalie.
La Prof:
Y mettre fin? Je pensais plutôt que vous
voudriez savoir comment en tirer profit.
Cyber-historienne:
La question ne se pose pas.
Vos ancêtres sont corrompues.
Ce sont maintenant des anachronismes, et lorsque
des anachronismes se présentent,
nous les éliminons.
Pourquoi croyez-vous que nous les avons laissées
venir ici?
Astrid:
A la moindre occasion, on se barre.
J'aime pas ce qui se passe.
Lucretia:
On pourrait essayer de voler une de leurs machines ?
Astrid:
Si tu m'aides, je connais une taverne à Saint-Domingue
qui sert le meilleur rhum de la Terre.
Lucretia:
Pourquoi pas.
Mais ensuite, nous rentrons à mon époque
et je te montre ce qu'est la vraie gastronomie.
Aliénor:
Mais Godefroy, qu'est-ce que vous faites ici?
Godefroy:
Je rentrais de la forêt où je vous ai croisée,
et une femme très étrange est venue m'aborder
pour me demander de venir lui parler de ma vie.
Dans le futur! Vous vous rendez compte?
Astrid:
Ben, oui, puisqu'on est ici aussi.
Vous êtes de la famille?
Aliénor:
Mais ça vous prend souvent de suivre des
maraudes au milieu des bois?
Godefroy:
Elle m'a assuré que ce n'était pas de la sorcellerie !
Et puis, elle vous ressemblait...
Astrid:
Ah, c'est ce que je pensais, vous êtes parents.
Aliénor:
Mais non! Comment ça, elle me ressemblait?
Godefroy:
Il y avait un vrai air de famille! Mis à
part les cheveux et l'habillement, que j'ai
trouvés plutôt étranges, mais...
Aliénor:
Mais c'est pas possible, on n'est pas parents,
on peut pas avoir la même descendante!
Aliénor:
Mais arrête toi!
Astrid:
Ah! J'ai compris!
Vous êtes mal...
La Prof:
...barrées, mais elles font de mal à personne
au XXIe siècle.
C'est déjà à peine si Lucretia bouge de
son canapé, d'habitude...
Par contre, je pourrais vous être utile.
Cyber-historienne:
Je vous écoute.
La Prof:
Si j'ai bien compris, vous vous basez sur
la mémoire de chacun de vos ancêtres pour
réécrire l'histoire de...
L'humanité, c'est ça?
Ça n'est pas une méthode très rigoureuse,
non? Leur mémoire peut être corrompue,
incomplète, manipulée par les questions
que vous leur posez ou par leurs émotions,
tous les bons historiens vous diront qu'on
ne peut pas se baser uniquement sur la mémoire
pour écrire l'Histoire.
Alors pardon, mais permettez-moi de douter
de vos compétences.
Cyber-historienne:
Vous avez une meilleure option?
La Prof:
Pourquoi ne pas utiliser vos machines pour
voyager dans le temps ? Aller explorer
les musées, les archives? Je sais pas quand
exactement elles sont vouées à disparaître,
ce n'est pas moi qui vient du XXIIIe siècle,
mais à mon époque on a encore pas mal de
documents exploitables.
Cyber-historienne:
Nos capacités sont limitées.
On ne peut voyager que pour aller vers l'un
de nos ancêtres grâce à la reconnaissance
ADN, et pour un temps très court.
C'est pour ça que nos agents ont eu autant
de difficultés à retrouver la pirate, la
romaine et la gueuse.
La Prof:
Heureusement qu'elle ne vous entend pas.
Pourquoi ne pas être passée par moi, alors?
Je suis historienne.
Cyber-historienne:
On...
Je ne m'intéresse pas vraiment au XXIe siècle,
en fait.
La Prof:
Bah...
Cyber-historienne:
Si je veux travailler sur l'histoire ancienne,
je travaille sur l'histoire ancienne, d'accord?
Enfin, si j'avais su toutes les anomalies
que vous causeriez...
La Prof:
Vous auriez foncé, parce que vous avez maintenant
la possibilité d'accéder aux connaissances
historiques du XXIe siècle, à travers moi.
Cyber-historienne:
Pardon?
La Prof:
Tant que vous épargnez les trois folles que
je me coltine, bien sûr.
Et les autres, s'il y en a d'autres.
A travers moi vous pouvez accéder aux archives,
aux livres d'Histoire, à tout ce que vous
voulez.
Je vous l'ai dit, on a pas mal de documents
à mon époque.
Si on sait les exploiter.
Je peux même vous compiler tout ça en vidéo
pour vous épargner la peine, je fais ça
tout le temps.
Cyber-historienne:
Et vos ancêtres? Je suis censée en faire
quoi, dans cette histoire?
Aliénor:
Mais attendez...
Si la Prof est ma descendante et la vôtre
aussi, alors qu'on est pas de la même famille,
ça veut dire que...
Astrid:
Sinon Lucretia cherche un fiancé, puisque
le sien est à 20 siècles d'ici.
La Prof:
J'imagine que les renvoyer à leur période
est hors de question?
Cyber-historienne:
En effet.
Je préfère qu'un double de mes ancêtres
apparaisse tranquillement pour prendre le
relais plutôt qu'une romaine avec un smartphone
qui débarquerait en plein Lutèce.
La Prof:
Pourtant dans Doctor Who, la plupart du temps ça passe...
Cyber-historienne:
Oh j'ADORE les 30e Docteurs...
Mais on est dans la réalité, ici.
Elles peuvent rentrer avec vous à votre époque,
qui est de toute façon assez déglinguée
pour qu'elles ne risquent pas d'être prises
au sérieux...
Ou bien rester ici.
On devrait pouvoir leur trouver une place,
même si je ne tiens pas à croiser mes ancêtres
à longueur de journée.
La Prof:
Oh, on s'y fait très vite.
Cyber-historienne:
J'ai du mal à le croire.
Enfin, il me semble que nous avons un accord.
Allons leur annoncer la nouvelle.
La Prof:
Aliénor?
Aliénor:
C'est elle qui est censée être mon sosie?!
Cyber-historienne:
Qu'est-ce que vous faisiez hors de votre salle?
Aliénor:
Je cherchais les toilettes.
Les ai pas trouvés.
On reste encore longtemps?
La Prof:
Justement, c'est de ça qu'on doit parler.
On y va?
Cyber-historienne:
Nous sommes parvenues à un accord.
Vous ne serez plus poursuivies.
Astrid:
Et en échange?
La Prof:
L'échange ne vous concerne pas, c'est entre
elle et moi.
Lucretia:
Ça signifie qu'on peut rentrer chez nous?
Cyber-historienne:
Non, par contre, on ne peut se le permettre.
Vous pouvez soit repartir avec votre descendante
au XXIe siècle et y vivre votre vie, soit
rester ici et on vous trouvera une place,
bien que l'idée de vous côtoyer ne m'enchante
pas plus que ça.
Lucretia:
Moi non plus.
Godefroy:
Ça veut dire qu'Aliénor va rester ici?
Et moi?
La Prof:
Non, en fait le système est plutôt bien
pensé, il y aura une Aliénor ici et une
autre au XVe siècle...
Donc techniquement, ça ne change pas le cours
de l'Histoire.
Sinon, t'es qui?
Aliénor:
Deux Aliénor?!
Cyber-historienne:
Attendez, il n'a plus rien à faire là, cet ancêtre.
Thierry, ramenez-le avant qu'il n'en sache
trop.
Agent Thierry:
Il me semble qu'au XVe siècle mes ancêtres
vivaient à Venise, ça ira?
Cyber-historienne:
Parfait, il visitera du pays.
Allez, hop.
Aliénor:
Mais...
Agent:
C'est fait.
Ça PUE, Venise, à cette époque!
Aliénor:
Mais je le reverrai plus jamais?!
Lucretia:
Dis-toi que lui te reverra, si ça te soulage.
Quoique l'idée que mon fiancé épouse une
autre Lucretia ne m'enchante guère.
Aliénor:
A sa place, ça m'enchanterait pas non plus.
Cyber-historienne:
Bon, à vous de choisir.
Vous repartez, ou vous restez.
Astrid:
Vous avez des vaisseaux spatiaux?
Cyber-historienne:
Oui, on va dans l'espace.
Astrid:
Y'a moyen que j'y aille aussi?
Lucretia:
Tu n'y penses pas?!
Cyber-historienne:
Pas de problème, mais il faut pas vous attendre
à des sauts dans l'hyperespace ou des conneries
du genre.
Astrid:
Ça c'est parce que j'étais pas encore là.
J'en suis.
Lucretia:
Lâcheuse!
Astrid:
Je serai la première pirate de l'espace!
Lucretia:
Je rentre au XXIe siècle.
Cette époque-ci n'est vraiment pas pour moi.
La gueuse, tu viens?
Aliénor:
Ouais l'antiquité.
Cyber-historienne:
Parfait! Thierry, vous pouvez...
Et n'oubliez pas ta part du marché.
Je reviendrai vite vous voir.
La Prof:
J'oublierai pas.
L'agent:
Prêtes?
Lucretia:
Nous oublie pas non plus, la Pirate.
Aliénor:
Attendez, je veux pas partir...
Cyber-historienne:
Quelle cholvaterie...
La Prof:
C'est quoi ce bordel?
Thierry:
C'est bête, mais je crois que mon ancêtre
est parti en vacances.
Il est plus du tout chez lui !
Lucretia:
Mais ramenez-nous!
Thierry:
J'essaie, j'essaie, mais le froid perturbe mon appareil...
Aliénor:
Mais c'est pas possible! Mais...
Voyages temporels de merde !